in 1996 Michael Jordan and Bugs Bunny
believed they could fly in family comedy
space jam in 2017 it looks like Warner
Brothers believes they can make a lot of
money with a sequel I'm Simon and this
is your Looney Tunes news update
according to The Hollywood Reporter a
sequel to Space Jam has been in the
works for years now it looks like the
long-awaited sequel is moving forward as
fast and furious director Justin Lin has
come aboard to direct with NBA star
LeBron James attached to play the lead
role rumors about James's involvement
emerged when his company springhill
entertainment reached a deal with Space
Jam studio Warner Brothers last summer
if the news report is accurate it won't
be James his first acting gig as he also
played himself in Amy Schumer's 2015
comedy trainwreck basketball icon
Michael Jordan played the lead role in
the original space jam which reportedly
made more than 230 million dollars
during it box office run the movie which
combined live action and animation saw
Jordan play a very important game of
basketball with Looney Tunes characters
such as Bugs Bunny and Daffy Duck Justin
Lin has directed for Fast and Furious
movies the most recent of which was
2013's 406 his latest project is Star
Trek beyond which comes to theaters this
July do you think James can out-jump
Jordan or do you think it should be
that's all folks for any more bugs bunny
adventures let us know in the comments
or come find me on Twitter I'm at the j
gun or thanks for watching for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot